لا نبحث عن حرب في الحدود الشماليه لكن
مقاومه لبنان تلعب بالنار هكذا قالها رئيس
دوله الكيان الولايات المتحده ترسل قادتها
لمساعده قياده الكيان بينما يصل الرئيس
الفرنسي اراضي الكيان ليعلن التضامن الصين
تعلنها لتل ابيب لكل الدول الحق في الدفاع
عن نفسها لكن مع الالتزام بالقانون
الانساني الدولي الاتحاد الاوروبي يدافع
عن المقاومه الفلسطينيه وايطاليا تتدخل
للوساطه مئات الالاف من الامريكيين
يستعدون للاجراء من الشرق الاوسط ما الذي
يجري وروسيا توجه نداء فوريا
للمقاومه الدول تكشف
اوراقها اوراق الحرب تتكشف وكل يكشف عن
صفه فاما الى هذا الطرف او ذاك ولا مكان
للحياد هنا وصل الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل
ماكرون الى الا ابيب للتعبير عن تضامن
فرنسا الكامل مع الكيان وفق ما ذكرت وكاله
فرانس بريس هناك قال رئيس الكيان يتسحاق
هرتسوغ خلال استقباله ماكرون ان الكيان لا
يبحث عن جبهه على الحدود الشماليه لكن
مقاومه لبنان تلعب بالنار وفق ما نقل موقع
واين ليخرج وزير الخارجيه الصيني وانجي
ويؤكد لنظيره في الكيان ان لكل الدول الحق
في الدفاع عن نفسها مشددا على انه في
الوقت نفسه يتعين على هذه الدول الالتزام
بالقانون الانساني الدولي وحمايه سلامه
المدنيين وذلك في اول اتصال بين الوزيرين
منذ نشوب الحرب بين الكيان والمقاومه في
السابع من اكتوبر واضاف وانجي ان بيكين
ستبذل قصار جهدها لدعم الجهود التي تؤدي
الى السلام الجانب الغربي يعود للتخبط
فعلى الجانب الامريكي اعلن موقع اوكسيو
الامريكي ان اد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ارسلت جنرالا من المارينز الامريكي
والعديد من الضباط العسكريين الامريكيين
الاخرين الى تل ابيب للمساعده في تقديم
المشوره لقياده جيش الكيان في عمليته في
غزه من جهته قال مفوض السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيب بوريل في ختام
اجتماع لوزراء الخارجيه الاتحاد ان حق
الكيان في الدفاع عن نفسه ليس بلا حدود
وانه لا يتضمن قطع الكهرباء والماء سكان
قطاع غزه بوريل عاد لينفي استخدام مقاومه
فلسطين لموارد الاتحاد الاوروبي المخصصه
للفلسطينيين فيما حذر وزير الدفاع
الايطالي جويدو كروزيت تو من تحويل الصراع
الفلسطيني مع الكيان لعداء جديد بين الغرب
والاسلام وشدد كروزيت تو على ان ايطاليا
من جانبها تتحرك بمدار 360 درجه بحيث يكون
هناك تراجع في حده تصعيد الصراع بحسب ما
ذكرت وكاله اكي ال الاطاليه في الجانب
الروسي وجهت موسكو نداء فوريا للمقاومه
حيث صرح الناطق باسم الكريملين ديميتري
بيسكوف بان روسيا تدعو المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الى الافراج الفوري عن جميع
الرهائن المحتجزين لديها بالعوده الى
امريكا تعهد البنتاجون بالرد بشكل حازم
على اي تصعيد ضد القوات الامريكيه في
المنطقه على خلفيه الهجمات التي طالت
قواعده في العراق وسوريا واتهم البنتاجون
ايران بدعم الفصائل المسلحه التي تستهدف
القوا الامريكيه وها هو المصدر امامكم
تؤكد واشنطن على لسان المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي جون كيربي ان ايران بصماتها
جليه فيها عبر اذرعها المتمثله بالفصائل
المسلحه المواليه لها قبل ان ننتقل الى
الميدان ذكرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تستعد لاحتمال
ان يحتاج مئات الالاف من مواطنيها الى
الاجلاء من الشرق الاوسط اذا لم يتم
احتواء اراقه الدماء في غزه الان ميدانيا
افادت وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه نقلا عن
مصادر طبيه بمقتل 110 وجرح المئات بقطاع
غزه اثر غارات جويه للكيان استهدفت العديد
من المنازل في خان يونس ورفح وجباليا
ومخيم البريج ومنطقه القراره فيما افادت
قناه ار تي بان قوات الكيان اقتحمت بلده
جبع جنوب الجنين في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
واعلنت قوات امن كيان انها اعتقلت الاسير
المحرر عدنان حمارشه القياديه في المقاومه
بعد مداهمه منزله في بلده يعبد لتعلن
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل
5300 فلسطيني واصابه 18000 اخرين منذ بدء
الحرب في قطاع غزه بينما قالت صحيفه
النيويورك تايمز نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين
ان اداره بايدن قلقه من افتقار اسرائيل
الى اهداف عسكريه قابله للتحقيق في غزه
وقلقه كذلك من ان جيش الكيان ليس مستعدا
بعد لشن غزو بري بخطه يمكن ان تنجح من
جهته اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد
اوستون لنظيره في الكيان على الحاجه الى
دراسه متانيه للكيفه التي قد تقوم بها
قوات الكيان بغزو بري لغزه وبخصوص ارسال
الجنرال الامريكي جيمس جلين للكيان قال
المسؤولون الامريكيون للصحيفه ان ذلك لا
يعني ان البنتاغون يتخذ القرارات نيابه عن
تلبيب وان الجنرال جلين لن يكون موجودا
على الارض في الكيان اذا بدا جيشها في
التوغل في غزه